by the way Nick The Bachelor the guy who
is the actual bachelors here there here
you are you're taller than I thought
exactly the fantasy suite is actual sex
that goes on I assume that's the point
of it well you want it it can happen
yeah I know what's happened with
certainly yes I've like you were all
upset and crying when that call broke up
with you but you got the Banger and I'm
like hey why is he upset you know what I
mean seriously you know sometimes that
that world can even for me I've been a
victim of letting the emotions of that
world get to me and I've learned that
lesson but certainly the sex is a part
of any relationship and Bachelor is
about relationships and that can happen
to any of the girls have bad breath
like are you like kind of glad
mentioning me well yeah I'm sure I mean
isn't that a major time this point I
would say in general bad breath is the
biggest turnoff for me but thankfully
there's a lot of Listerine floating
around the bachelor mashes do you know
what I mean by vocal fry no women are
now talking like this
last night you threw a girl off I know
why because the way she's talking to the
Danielle we got out of Rosa how long
immediately know a great time he doesn't
[ __ ] throw her around I said there's
something wrong I mean I can't so much I
totally like a that's my head she's part
frog giggin ice does that get to you a
lot of the girls have it she's a sweet
girl I think for me and specifically
with Danielle is like sometimes you just
want them to kind of just be honest you
know don't tell me what you think I want
to hear just put yourself out there say
something that maybe even makes me go
huh like I'm surprised me I mean when
Raven kind of talked about her past
relationship and her boyfriend cheating
on her I mean it was sort of a
surprising story but even for me I was
like you know this is someone who can
just be open authentic and put it out
there I found it very interesting but
you don't notice their voices and it
doesn't turn you off when they're going
back there's some giggles and but that
are kind of weird yeah I I have my own
tics